tell us about your new special a flu
Anthropy yeah so flu lenska p is two
words nobody knows my name Flula and the
word philanthropy we are combine those
like in Voltron
you know Conan I'm trying to help the
word I know so how are you trying to
help the world well I am NOT as we are
not part of the scientific community so
I'm trying to like solve problems that
scientists are trying to solve like what
for example a warmer climate to change
oh you're trying to help solve the
climate change problem but I don't know
how like how does the chemistry work
what e equals MC don't know you know -
yeah so I am trying to find solutions to
help people to care about the
environment I see and this is what's
occurring hello aunty hello hi I you
have been sitting here I have I have
I've been listening the entire time it's
kutami yeah yeah Spanish alright so how
are you gonna help solve climate change
I'm hearing everyone saying oh boy man
those guys are really screwing the earth
who know why are they su no scott pruett
and the epa he's screwing the earth
everybody is screwing it so I did some
googles and I've realized that perhaps
don't screw the real earth maybe I can
provide some alternatives so show us
what you're thinking of it's I call it a
Big Bang ball big bang ball they are but
it has also a location for pleasures and
so here you go and yet so I think anyone
who is like considering to like oh let
me harm the earth let me ruin the
non-renewable resources no no showdown
showdown and see ya have a big bang ball
a nice time
why in why in different regions of the
earth explain how that why that would
make a difference what a conan different
as you say strokes for different people
so we have up if you like it maybe code
you want to melt your lover's heart we
have the North Pole yeah yeah if you
like it perhaps a hot end where we have
of course the Amazon okay and Andy is if
you are like preferring some lubrication
we have lots of oil and political issues
in the Middle East this is a very tricky
ball good one yeah yeah now and is it
just if you get this you just get the
ball obviously no conan's there's so
much more thank you for asking what else
is there Flula oh boy Conan O'Brien if
if you receive this boy you will also
receive a nice soundtrack to place you
into the mood oh what's here we hear it
what do we have zit has a teacher hey
teacher kick it kick it
[Music]
I see you there trust sitting over there
blatantly ignoring overwhelming
scientific evidence that climate change
is real and caused by humans don't be
shy come over to mama so I can take care
of those body Earth destroying purges
yes baby grab me by the equator and I
want you
I'm not gonna know now we're gonna stop
we stop that we're not gonna actually no
we're not gonna do have sex with these
balls right now I'll tell golden I've a
feeling your carbon footprint is
hold it I want to send this to all the
people who want to you know make
intercourse with us no slow down slow
your roll is have a big bang ball we'll
get the word out on that thank you
yeah well flu Anthropy is coming soon to
see so fluey you saved a lot of lives
here tonight thank you so much kono pine
and Andy rich that we do it what does
that mean I was don't didn't joy
enthusiasm
no that was terrific it just seems so
forced in the last second it was crazy
I love why you say Andy Richter's last
name - listo listo listo alright ha ha
ha helps in fights and shouts you are so
fluent Jill do you well I I don't speak
real German but when I speak fake German
you've said that every couple of words I
get something right you just said
something to the effect of outside
cheese house slime she's right this
gravel sweetened outdoor fire sled
[Laughter]
you